hey 42 here do you ever talk to yourself
no not out loud in your mind I'm talking
about that little voice in your head
that's often chips in throughout the day
to offer up some useful advice you know
the one that's saying I hate you over
and over again whilst your boss is
giving you a mighty fine rollicking
sometimes we even have entire
conversations with ourselves in our
heads we can also hear it when we read
it as if our mind is saying the words
out loud but only you can hear it what
causes that little voice inside your
head and what its purpose let's find out
you might call it Barbara or even Keith
but scientists actually have a proper
name for the voice in your head it's
called inner speech and it's been a
topic of extensive research for
centuries psychologists in particular
have been obsessed with it ever since
psychology began in the 1930s Russian
psychologist Lev Vygotsky put forward
the case that inner speech as a result
of the internalization of external
speech ought to put it in other words he
thought that inner speech is the exact
same process as external speech right up
until the point where noise exits our
mouths there may be some truth to this
field in the 90s neuroscientists use
normal imaging techniques to discover
that an area of the brain called Broca's
area which is responsible for fine motor
skills involved with speech was active
during inner speech as well as normal
speech this means that the muscles and
organs that move when we speak such as
the larynx also move when we speak to
ourselves in our minds despite there
being absolutely no reason for such
muscles and organist to do so this can
only mean that the systems in our brain
that govern external speech and inner
speech are very closely linked or maybe
even the same the two systems are so
intrinsically linked for good reason
because inner speech is actually a
prediction of what we're about to say
researcher Mark Scott added
Hartman's of linguistics of the
university of british columbia let us
study which explored a brain signal
known as corollary discharge this signal
is a copy of a motor signal that is sent
to the brain to alert the brain that we
are about to move so the brain knows to
react accordingly and most importantly
not to overreact the purpose of
corollary discharge is to separate
sensory experiences that come from
outside our body and ones that we
produce ourselves it allows our brain to
predict our own movements before we
actually make them this is why we can't
tickle ourselves because before you even
start to tickle yourself a corollary
discharge signal has already been sent
to the brain to alert it that you're
about to tickle yourself and so your
brain completely ignores the sensation
of being tickled the system is primarily
used to determine the difference between
an external threat and something that we
do ourselves and should therefore be
considered non-threatening our brain
utilizes corollary discharge in a very
ingenious way when we speak if corollary
discharge didn't exist when we talk our
voice will be overwhelmingly liable
because our ears are so close to the
source of the sound our own voice would
sound so loud that it would drown out
every other noise around us and we won't
be able to hear anything but our own
voice and no matter how much some people
just love the sound of their own voice
that will get bloody annoying after a
while however when we speak corollary
discharges used to predict that we are
going to produce a noise and so our
brain dampens the sound of that noise
the result is that our own voice sounds
quieter to us than to everyone else
amazingly our brain does this self voice
filtering without affecting the volume
of voices from other people so why do we
have a voice inside our heads our brains
are able to plan sentences in our minds
before we actually say them the brain is
also really good at replaying sounds
that we've heard before
just try imagining any sound you've
heard
before throughout your life be it a
police siren or birds tweeting when you
think about these past sounds you can
actually hear it it's almost as if it's
being replayed inside your head so when
our brain plans a sentence it replays
the sentence inside our head and this is
what we refer to as the voice in our
head or in a speech because of corollary
discharge the brain knows which
sentences should be spoken out loud and
which are meant for our ears only and
therefore should be replayed as inner
speech in our mind the brain heavily
utilizes inner speech when we read
because it helps our brain to better
understand the words on the page and
remember them
scientists believe that people with
dyslexia have a harder time reading and
understanding words because they have no
inner voice it may be hard to imagine
but most dyslexic people don't
understand the concept of a voice inside
their head because they quite simply
don't have what they instead visualize
and understand everything in pictures
instead of words for most people inner
voice is an automatic process and we can
hear it every minute of the day the
rating our lives planning and predicting
what we're about to say and
communicating to us what we are reading
in real time some dyslexic individuals
have no grasp of this concept and simply
don't experience it that's why they
often move their mouth whilst reading
because they don't have the luxury of a
voice inside their head reading it for
them to help them to easier understand
the text young children do the exact
same thing because we don't develop the
skill of an inner voice until later on
in childhood until children learn this
skill like tend to say everything out
loud for better or for worse it may at
times seem like a little devil inside
your head coercing you to do unruly
things perhaps telling you punch your
boss in the face go on do it but it is
in fact just your brain planning and
even predicting what you're about to say
even if you don't end up actually saying
it
because it may be the case that only you
need to hear it and let's be honest
that's usually for the best thanks for
the view subscribe for more 42
you